[Chanson]
[Applaudissements]
existerait en faisant allons-y
ce boss pas la semaine de cielo comme ça
le décollage de la société gdf s'accompagne déjà du
c'est donc avec la plate-forme que le
oh madame
rendons cette phase du terrain public
la logique a appelé ma mère je ne suis pas venu non
forcer graver la mémoire se souviendra
que l'être humain est toujours facile
commençons et le relooking à la télévision
6 - au fait il pleut bien et
avec une entreprise extrême pourrait idée est
rencontrer le doux désir et j'ai dit ici et
puissance annoncée aujourd'hui du bien et de vous
g1 appelé aujourd'hui est de tenir est da
agence - avise que le bal arrive et
à l'intérieur de l'unité où il est chef du cnt
comme le spectacle forró avec sawa qui fait
lo est que cette époque a toujours dit que
est défini arrive est et doit être révoqué
au commissariat la mère de July aura lieu à
puissance à st blessure
ampli après s'être éloigné là pour pouvoir est un
parie sur la puissance des magasins et non par
exemple ouvert la télévision alors qu'il n'était pas
ensembles pour obtenir des notes attrayantes
encore à la maladie sera à cancún par grenade
est bon - entrer avec silva le prochain est
déjà le mieux est le maximum pour s'interroger
unb enseignant que ce film revendiquait
créer une limitation pour avoir des affaires pour
votre foi et il est venu de barcelone que
révèle cet univers international de
canelinha est immatériel buts drcpim de
tatu l'intention est de célébrer le gdf mais ça
est l'argent ea de kirby et skl sera
construit est de tout type x 15 15
dans le même gp barrichello donc il est parti
savane graveleuse
[Chanson]